foreign
on this Saturday night to one of the
biggest strikes in Canadian history
looming
final push to avoid a federal workers
strike our goal is to get to a tentative
agreement the demands at the weekend
negotiating table and how a strike could
affect you
clashes in Khartoum the violent power
struggle erupting in Sudan as civilians
take cover
revisiting one of Canada's most infamous
criminal cases new information four
years later in a BC killing spree
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us the union representing roughly half
of the staff of the Canadian public
service is ready to strike talks are
taking place this weekend between Ottawa
and the bargaining units representing
workers essential to the basic
functioning of the federal government
from clerks and maintenance workers to
Coast Guard search and rescue teams to
the people who process passport
applications job action could even
impact the timing of your tax return
Mackenzie gray has our top story tonight
it could be one of the biggest strikes
in Canadian history 155
000 federal civil servants are ready to
walk out an overwhelming majority of our
members have told us they can't wait any
longer and they are prepared to strike
to secure a fair deal that won't see
them fall behind the public service
Alliance that Canada and the federal
government have been in collective
bargaining since June 2021 but they've
yet to come to a deal the key sticking
point compensation
the union says the majority of their
members are in between forty thousand
and sixty five thousand dollars annually
and to deal with inflation they want a
13.5 wage increase over three years the
treasury board proposal just over eight
percent for the next four we have some
of the lowest paid workers within the
federal public service and those workers
are currently relying on food banks in
order to feed their families but it's
not just wages there are numerous other
issues the two sides can't agree on the
most contentious might be the unions
asked to have the right to work from
home included in the Collective
Agreement a non-starter for the feds
most employers have traditionally said
well wait a second that's a that's a
pretty basic management right uh where
are you going to do the work and how you
do the work it has to be up to us but if
public servants do strike over the right
to work from home the union has said
they can't strike from home which means
Canadians needing Federal Services might
be met with picket lines treasury report
outlined 23 different departments that
would be impacted by a strike passport
processing would be be paired down
immigration applications would grind to
a halt and the CRA might be slow in
issuing tax returns but those
inconveniences could be avoided the two
sides are still negotiating and Mona
Forte the minister responsible saying
the feds remain committed to reaching a
deal at the bargaining table as soon as
possible leaving some hope a deal could
get done as for when a strike had
happened psac is now in a 60-day window
so it could be any time until early June
but experts say rolling strikes and work
to rule or a more likely First Step far
up
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you
Mackenzie Japanese prime minister fumio
kashida was evacuated out of a campaign
event today after someone threw an
explosive device in his Direction
[Applause]
police took down the suspect after he
threw the object with an exploding
moments later officials now say it
appears to be a smoke bomb no injuries
were reported the 24 year old suspect is
in custody and kashida carried on his
campaign schedule this afternoon
another setback to recent hopes if an
eventual transition to democracy in
Sudan dozens of people have been killed
in Fierce clashes after they erupted in
the capital city of Khartoum today
between the military and a powerful
paramilitary force the Army has told
civilians to stay inside and as Reggie
chakini explains the violence is also
raising fears of a water conflict
the billowing plumes of smoke were not
enough to smolder the piercing sounds of
gunfire in Sudan's capital city as
months of violence escalated within the
nation's military leadership on one side
the national Army on the other a
powerful paramilitary group known as the
rapid support forces historically the
pattern has been that
the military have dominated politics in
Sudan since Independence fighting is
reported to have started at a military
base and spread to the presidential
Palace which the rsf claimed it took
charge of control of Sudan is now in
question and the volatility has left
countries including Canada to issue
travel bans
the exchange of fire must stop
immediately the country's former prime
minister said the voice of reason must
rule or everyone will lose
Abdullah hamdak was ousted by these two
leaders during a power-sharing coup in
2021 that followed the 2019 overthrow of
then president Omar al-Bashir bringing
partial civilian rule but a battle over
influence From Within These parallel
militaries turned them on each other
they've both been trying to play their
own kind of political game with
different sets of civilians and it is
civilians that are caught in the
crosshairs
this Sudanese citizen says the generals
are fighting getting over power and we
are fighting for food and drink it's a
fragile situation expressing concern
America's top Diplomat was among many
world leaders calling for an end to
hostilities or risk endangering a
framework agreed to some weeks ago this
is a real opportunity to finally carry
forward the civilian-led transition and
one that we and in other countries
are trying to to bolster
with numerous attempted coups since
Sudan's Independence in the 1950s this
latest burst of violence could tilt the
country towards collapse and derail a
path to elections regich can you Global
News
French president Emmanuel Macau has
finally signed a deeply unpopular bill
into law that raises the state pension
age from 62 to 64. in an interview on
French broadcaster tf1 today a
government spokesperson said they will
continue their dialogue with unions the
legislation is expected to take effect
on September 1st but the government says
it won't be fully implemented until the
end of Mecca's term in 2027. protests
which have been going on for weeks are
expected to continue unions are
encouraging workers to turn out for
full-scale Marches On France's Labor Day
which is May 1st
in Ukraine at least 11 people were
killed in a Russian missile strike in
the eastern city of slovensk
Rescuers work to clear rubble from
residential buildings searching for
survivors it's one of two Eastern cities
coveted by Russian forces as fighting
rages on in bakmut Ukrainian Air Force
says that the country will soon have the
weapons to prevent such attacks say
Patriot air defense system promised by
the U.S is expected to arrive after
Easter
and the U.S is still grappling with an
aftermath of a major security breach
that saw hundreds of top secret files
leak onto the internet the documents
contained highly sensitive information
about the war in Ukraine and
intelligence not only on Washington's
adversaries but on its allies as well
despite that the U.S Secretary of State
says that hasn't impacted America's ties
with its partners
what I've heard so far
at least is an appreciation for the the
steps that we're taking and it's not
affected
our cooperation I just haven't seen that
haven't heard that
a 21 year old low-ranking I.T specialist
with the Air National Guard was arrested
and charged late this week for the
breach but on this weekend's edition of
the West block our Mercedes Stevenson
speaks with former U.S ambassador to
Nato Kurt volcker about the wide-ranging
Fallout over these documents Mercedes
borrow the former U.S ambassador to Nato
says the real risk of this massive
intelligence breach is not the
information in the documents but
critical Clues they reveal about how the
U.S gathers information from both
technological and human sources that
forms its intelligence picture and that
knowledge could lead adversaries like
Russia or China to close those gaps
making it harder for the U.S and allies
who it disseminates that intelligence to
to gather accurate information volcker
says a key takeaway from the leak is
also that while the U.S is very very
good at Gathering those large amounts of
intelligence it is far less skilled at
understanding what the information
actually means we do a great job of
collecting intelligence but when you
look at the quality of the analysis it's
often coming up short and I'm reminded
that for instance the beginning of the
war last year in Ukraine when Russia
accelerated its Invasion we were
predicting that Ukraine would fall
Russia would roll of Ukraine in a matter
of three days zielinski flee the country
and this was wildly wrong even though we
had the data right that Russia would
invade we didn't have the context right
according to volcker American officials
have to ask hard questions about the
level of experience of those Gathering
U.S intelligence in the field and
whether they are actually talking to
people on the ground or if they're too
far removed and relying on other sources
volcker also says that there needs to be
more stringent controls in place to
prevent future leaks pharah
Mercedes thank you and you can hear more
from mercedes's Interview with the
former Ambassador tomorrow on the
Westlock right here on global
Canada's escalating drug crisis worse
than before the pandemic coming up two
neighboring provinces with two very
different strategies in dealing with the
crisis
seven years ago this week BC declared a
state of emergency after toxic street
drugs began killing Canadians at an
alarming rate
seven years later overdose deaths
particularly in western Canada continue
to soar this week Alberta quietly
released its 2022 data showing that
while deaths dipped slightly last year
toxic drugs are killing at least four
people every day in neighboring BC the
numbers are even worse our Heather
York's West looks at why the problem
just keeps getting worse
Angela Staines lives in fear that at any
day a toxic drug dose will kill her son
we've gotten him on methadone but if we
don't have the other services to support
him and he ends up going back to it back
to the illicit Supply
he's at an increased risk for drug
poisoning Alberta saw
1498 drug poisoning deaths in 2022
that's down slightly from 2021's record
high but still up significantly compared
to pre-pandemic levels the numbers
follow the same trend line as
neighboring BC where so far this year
overdose calls are at a record high
we're averaging right now close to 3 300
calls a month for overdose events and
that's up from about 2 800 in the year
before together with Ontario BC and
Alberta account for more than 85 percent
of Canada's drug overdose deaths but the
two Western provinces have approached
the crisis from very different
perspectives with BC emphasizing harm
reduction decriminalization and safe
Supply while Alberta has emphasized
treatment and Recovery however neither
approach has been successful I think the
key is to scale these different
approaches to a population level and we
haven't seen that in either jurisdiction
as a result Elaine hishka says there are
still many people in BC unable to access
a safe drug Supply while in Alberta
despite Promises of increased funding
people are facing long waits to access
drug treatment beds we have yet to see
even basic data showing that the number
of people who are accessing treatment
our province has actually gone up
[Applause]
but what has undeniably risen since 2016
is the number of people who've died it's
just been challenge after Challenge and
it's just gotten worse and after seven
years of an escalating crisis those
living with that daily fear are seeing
little hope that things will improve
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary
[Music]
ahead behind the scenes of one of the
biggest man hunts in Canadian history
revisiting a story that gripped the
nation
Global television's original True Crime
documentary series crime beat delves
into some of the country's most
high-profile homicides this week we're
taking a look at one of the biggest man
hunts in Canadian history a triple
murder in Northern British Columbia in
the summer of 2019.
it's the story of a young
australian-american couple killed on a
journey of a lifetime their bodies found
on the side of the highway and in an
exclusive interview the Widow and Sons
of the third murdered man Leonard dick
tells us about their experience
throughout the ordeal
tonight we take you back in time for a
first-hand look at how this tragic tale
began
we were there to help them like almost
like an angel there to help them in a
way
but yet that same day the complete
opposite of humanity hurt them
the worst ever love story
I realize something's wrong
when Mom goes can you text Dad he hasn't
responded to my messages in a while
I was like okay by Monday I'm gonna have
to start looking to see if there's any
accident reports see if there's anything
in the news
we begin with a pair of deadly Mysteries
raising concern in northern BC tonight
19 year old cam McLeod at 18 year old
Briar schmiegelski are missing their
burned out vehicle found on Highway 37
last Friday and a body which police
confirm is neither of the teens found at
a nearby Highway pullouts
and they had a drawing of
the person and I was like that's Len
I'm standing on the exact spot where the
two fugitives abandoned their vehicle
and then apparently set it on fire you
could see the wide area here that's been
scorched by the extreme heat
Jules Knox joins us now Jules this was a
story that really gripped our nation and
you had a chance to speak with
investigators in Manitoba who actually
revealed some new details that's right
the team fugitive sparked one of the
largest manhunts in Canadian history
they burnt their stolen vehicle and
headed off into the Wilderness we hear a
firsthand account from one of the
investigators who was on the ground when
some of the key discoveries were made
and those Clues helped police to narrow
the search for the murder suspects in
fact Manitoba RCMP reveals some alarming
details about what exactly they found in
the bush that led them to believe that
at one point the teens might have set up
an ambush for officers or anybody else
walking nearby
we located three different areas where
there was
caches of ammunition do you think that
the teams were lying in weight I do yeah
why do you think they didn't shoot the
distance between where the vehicle was
and where we located the these
ammunition points was actually quite far
you know you worked on the server for
quite some time Jules so what kind of
research went into it we spoke with the
victims families and investigators and
we also spent hours going through
hundreds of pages of search warrants and
those documents were key in helping us
piece together what exactly police knew
and when RCMP came under Fire for
withholding information at times
throughout this investigation and these
search warrants show us what they did
know versus what they were telling the
public of course we know that there is
hold back in evidence in investigations
and RCMP aren't able to release
everything at the time but the search
warrants really offer an insight into
just how exactly this police operation
unfolded on a scale that we don't get to
see very often what else stood out to
you Jules as you were reporting on this
story
what was important to me was remembering
the victims here especially when we sat
down with Leonard Dick's family it
really came through how senseless these
killings were Len's Widow and Sons
shared their journey of grief with us
but it was also very important for them
to express their forgiveness
now part two of this episode airs next
week on April 21st what can we expect
from that
in the second episode we'll follow the
suspect's footsteps as they Traverse the
country and then the Wilderness the
teams also shot several videos on a
camera that police recovered we'll learn
about those from investigators and we'll
also take a closer look at what we know
of the big question here why this all
happened
motive that is the big question okay
Jules Knox thanks so much
and you can catch the second part off
The Manhunt Friday April 21st on crime
beat right here on global
coming up next the hunt for hockey's
Ultimate Prize why this year's NHL
playoff could be won for the history
books
and Canadian hockey fans are primed and
ready for the NHL playoffs starting on
Monday three Canadian teams are all in
the running all hoping to hold Lord
Stanley's cup when all is said and done
but as Eric Sorensen reports the
spotlight is shining bright on Edmonton
even by his own Transcendent standards
Conor McDavid has outdone himself the
first nhler to score 150 points in a
season since Mario Lemieux 27 years ago
so dangerous with the puck he not only
outscored the rest of the league he
distributed more goals for teammates to
score it seems like there's Conor
McDavid then there's the rest of the NHL
essentially almost better than anybody
else at a whole bunch of things not just
one or two aspects of his game in the
history of the NHL only seven players
have led the league in both goals and
assists the same year New Zealand Howie
morenz Gordy Howe in the first half
century of the league then there was
Phil Esposito Wayne Gretzky and Mario
Lemieux and how many times times Well
only Howe and Gretzky and Lemieux have
done so more than once Gretzky five
times but now Conor McDavid joins this
August group and with a long career
still ahead of him not only is he the
best player in the world but he can play
in any situation Edmonton's coach even
uses McDavid to kill penalties these
days everybody's been playing well
everybody McDavid almost always
redirects questions about personal
achievements towards the team's
accomplishments it was a good regular
season individually and for the team
um you know but now is that was a fun
time
Funtime means playoff time the Oilers
are the hottest team going into the
playoffs just about every fan is decked
out in Euler's gear this time of year
it's infectious for the players it's so
much fun everyone in every store that
you go to is wearing Oilers jerseys I
can't wait uh it's going to be a lot of
fun and use the energy that the fans
give us like McDavid individually this
year there has been one team that has
been truly exceptional the Boston Bruins
set an all-time record for points in a
season the other top Canadian team the
Toronto Maple Leafs could face the
unenviable task of meeting the Bruins in
the playoffs and that's only if the
Leafs get to the second round which they
haven't done in almost 20 years I think
Leaf fans have such low expectations
that one round win will be like let's
check a parade route anyway ha the Leafs
making a run for the Stanley Cup might
be a hockey fairy tale but fantasies
aside this has been an historic hockey
season that saw one extraordinary player
and one record-breaking team and should
the Bruins and Conor mcdavid's Oilers
face off it would come in the Stanley
Cup finals Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser thanks
for spending part of your evening with
us tonight's your Canada is Corner Brook
Newfoundland and Labrador until tomorrow
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good night
[Music]
thank you